Est-ce que je vais devenir asexuée ? »
De ce que je savais de la MGF,
son but entier était de contrôler la sexualité des femmes.
Ainsi, nous n'avons aucun désir sexuel.
J'ai dit : « Est-ce que je suis asexuée ?
Est-ce que je vais vivre le reste de ma vie sans avoir envie de sexe,
sans aimer le sexe ? »
Elle ne pouvait pas répondre à mes questions,
et elles restèrent sans réponse.
Lorsque j'ai commencé à avoir mes règles vers mes 14 ans,
j'ai réalisé qu'elles n'étaient pas normales à cause de la MGF.
Mes règles étaient abondantes, longues et très douloureuses.
Puis on m'a dit que j'avais des fibromes.
Ce sont comme des petites boules.
L'un d'eux recouvrait l'une de mes ovaires.
Puis vint la grande nouvelle.
« Nous ne pensons pas que vous puissiez avoir des enfants, Khadija. »
Une fois de plus, j'étais une femme noire en colère.
Je suis rentrée à la maison et ai dit à ma mère :
« Ton acte, peu importe ce que tu pourrais dire pour ta défense —
car elle pensait qu'elle l'avait fait par amour —
ce que tu as fait par amour me fait du mal.
Qu'est-ce que tu as à dire ? »
Elle a dit : « J'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire en tant que mère. »
J'attends toujours une excuse, à ce propos.
Puis je me suis mariée.
Et une fois encore —
la MGF est ce cadeau qui n'en finit pas.
On s'en rend compte rapidement.
Le sexe était très douloureux.
Ça faisait tout le temps mal.
J'ai réalisé qu'ils m'avaient dit : « Vous ne pouvez pas avoir d'enfants. »
J'ai songé : « C'est ça mon existence ? Est-ce que c'est ça, la vie ? »
Je suis fière de vous dire,
il y a cinq mois,
on m'a annoncé que j'étais enceinte.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis chanceuse.
Il y a tant de femmes qui ont enduré une MGF
et qui sont stériles.
Je connais une fille de neuf ans qui est incontinente,
qui a des infections constantes, des douleurs.
C'est ce cadeau. Ça n'arrête jamais.
Ça touche chaque partie de votre vie.
Ça m'est arrivé car je suis née fille
au mauvais endroit.
C'est pour ça que ça m'est arrivé.
Je dirige toute cette colère, toute cette douleur, dans le soutien
parce que j'avais besoin que cette douleur vaille quelque chose.
Je suis la directrice d'une organisation appelée No FGM Australia.
Vous m'avez bien entendue.
Pourquoi No FGM Australia ?
Les MGF sont en Australie.
Il y a deux jours, j'ai dû appeler les services de protection de l'enfance,
parce que quelque part en Australie,
il y a une fille de quatre ans,
dont la mère prévoit de lui faire subir une MGF.
Cette enfant est en maternelle. Je vais vous laisser réfléchir.
Quatre ans.
Il y a quelques mois, j'ai rencontré une dame mariée à un homme malaisien.
Son mari est rentré un jour à la maison et dit qu'il allait amener leurs filles
en Malaisie pour leur retirer le clitoris.
Elle a dit : « Pourquoi ? » Il a dit qu'elles étaient sales.
Elle a dit : « Tu m'as bien épousée. »
Il a dit : « C'est ma croyance culturelle. »
Puis ils ont parlé et elle lui a dit :
« Tu devras me passer sur le corps si tu comptes faire ça à mes filles. »
Mais imaginez si cette femme ne savait pas ce qu'étaient les MGF,
s'ils n'avaient jamais eu cette conversation ?
Ses enfants auraient été envoyées en Malaisie
et elles seraient revenues changées pour le reste de leurs vies.
Savez-vous combien de millions de dollars
sont nécessaires pour traiter un tel problème ?
[Trois enfants par jour] en Australie
courent le risque de subir une MGF.
C'est un problème australien.
Ce n'est pas un problème africain, ni du Moyen-Orient.
Ce n'est pas blanc, ni noir. Ça n'a aucune couleur.
C'est un problème qui touche tout le monde.
Les MGF sont de la maltraitance des enfants.
C'est de la violence contre les femmes.
Ça dit que les femmes n'ont pas le droit au plaisir sexuel.
Ça dit que nous n'avons pas de droits sur notre corps.
Je dis non à ça, et vous savez quoi ? Conneries.
C'est ce que j'ai à dire à ce sujet.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis fière d'apporter ma contribution pour en finir avec les MGF.
Qu'allez-vous faire ?
Il existe peut-être un enfant dans votre classe qui est à risque.
Il existe peut-être un patient qui vient à votre hôpital
qui est à risque.
C'est la réalité.
Même dans notre chère Australie,
l'endroit le plus merveilleux du monde,
les enfants sont maltraités à cause d'une culture.
La culture ne devrait pas justifier la maltraitance des enfants.
Je veux que chacun d'entre vous voie les MGF comme son propre problème.
Rendez ce problème personnel.
Ça pourrait être votre fille, votre sœur, votre cousine.
Je ne peux combattre les MGF toute seule.
Je pourrais essayer, mais je ne peux pas.
Je vous lance un appel, s'il vous plaît, rejoignez-moi.
Signez ma pétition sur Change.org.
Tapez Khadija, mon nom, la pétition va apparaître et signez-la.
Son but est de venir en aide aux victimes de MGF en Australie,
de s'assurer que les petites filles qui grandissent ici
soient protégées de cette pratique abominable.
Chaque enfant a le droit au plaisir.
Chaque enfant mérite que son corps soit laissé intact,
et bon sang, chaque enfant a le droit d'avoir un clitoris.
S'il vous plaît, rejoignez-moi pour qu'on en finisse avec ça.
Ma citation préférée est :
« Pour que le mal triomphe,
seule suffit l'inactivité des gens de bien. »
Allez-vous laisser cette abomination qu'est la mutilation génitale féminine
triompher en Australie ?
Je ne pense pas.
Alors, rejoignez-moi pour garantir sa disparition avec ma génération.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)